Why didn't you write me?
Why?
It wasn't over for me. I waited for you
for 7 years and now it's too late.
>> I wrote you 365 letters.
I wrote you every day for a year.
>> You wrote me?
>> Yes.
>> Wasn't over.
I used to binge romantic movies without
realizing how much they were shaping my
view of love and of marriage. The
problem is that most of those stories
are completely unrealistic. So, just
think about it. So many of these films
send the message that you're not with
your real soulmate. So, it's okay to
cheat on your spouse and chase after
your so-called one true love.
Travis, this is Ryan McCarthy, my
boyfriend.
>> Hey. Hi. Don't make a thing out of it.
>> I know you. And my big brother does not
like it when things don't come easy.
>> Why do you make it so hard for me to
flirt with you?
>> If I made it easy, you wouldn't flirt
anymore.
>> What are you doing?
>> Walking towards you real slow.
>> Why?
>> Cuz if I ran, I'd scare you.
>> In Hollywood's version of love, sex and
passion are at the center of the
relationship.
>> You don't know how to flirt, do you?
Awesome.
>> Yes, I blew it the other day.
>> You did? Well, what are you going to do
about it?
>> Emotional maturity. Forget it. When
conflict shows up, couples don't work
things out. They scream, they pout, or
they throw a tantrum because that's what
makes a more dramatic scene.
>> I have a fiance waiting for me at a
hotel who's going to be crushed when he
finds.
>> So, you make love to me, and then you go
back to your husband. Was that your
plan? Was that a test that I didn't
pass?
>> I made a promise to a man. He gave me a
ring and I gave him my word.
>> And your word is shot to hell now, don't
you think?
>> I don't know. I'll find out when I talk
to him. The truth is, it's all a
counterfeit. So, in this episode, we're
diving head first into exposing
Hollywood's false system of romance and
more importantly uncovering God's
blueprint for real love and lasting
relationships. So whether or not you
play with social media a lot or you
watch a bunch of movies, what you're
really doing is looking at relationship
modeling often. So we've got Renee here
from all the way from South Africa and
we're excited to have you on the show.
So
>> it's great to be here.
>> Tell us why this matters.
>> It matters because God made us in his
image. Mhm.
>> We we are designed to
>> to want relationships
>> and the movies out there, social media
portrays this picture of what it's
supposed to look like.
>> And it's really modeled after how God
created us. And that's what we want to
look at today. How did God create us?
What are we attracted to in social
media, in movies, and video games?
>> It seems like that would make a little
bit of sense. Like if you were wanting
to be careful or that was a temptation
to you, if you kind of understand the
relationship aspect, that might give you
some tools to say, "Okay, I need to
avoid this kind of stuff because it's
going to lead me into that behavior."
Or,
>> you know, as wild now is people are
getting into relationships with
artificial intelligence.
>> Oh, true. Which, you know, it is
whatever you want it to be. So, it's
like a relationship fit for you, which
is not really a relationship at all, but
>> that's kind of the direction things are
are headed, you know, after movies like
what was it? Her I think.
>> Oh, they've done
>> what was that one?
>> It was like 10 years ago or something
where it was u Phoenix
>> and he got shipped a piece of software
that was a computer. He installed it and
it was like this AI program and he
started developing a relationship with
it.
>> Interesting.
>> And it it was basically like way ahead
of its time. M
>> so are they going to add another
category here for the uh relationships
on computer like
>> yeah right yeah so to add what you guys
are saying um you know I grew up not a
Christian and I grew up watching tons of
like those romantic relationship movies
and and you're always sitting there like
you're being drawn along in your
emotions you know and I think something
I start picking up on later on when I
became a Christian specifically in the
Nicholas Sparks movies he's the author
of like the notebook um the last song
with Miley Cyrus um that it's frequently
portrayed as, you know, you break the
rules, you rebel against your parents,
and specifically,
>> and this is a theme in a lot of these
romantic movies, the um if you're
already married, but you're supposed to
be with this other person, you it's okay
to cheat on your spouse and all of these
different things because
>> the your spouse is is shown as like this
lameo dude, whereas that's your prince
charming and so go with that person like
break the laws.
>> Yeah. Or they're or they're doing that
Disney theme where it's like wherever
your heart tells you to go. Like in
those films, they're always with the
wrong person. That's essentially every
plot line is you're with the wrong
person, you really should be with this
person.
>> And what's even weirder is like how
they're always the right person for them
that they're trying to tell you is the
right person is always somebody with bad
characteristics. So,
>> and it's always destiny.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, destiny is pointing you in
this direction.
>> Yes. Good point. Maybe there's also the
the hallmark hallmark destiny.
>> It's always destined that you leave the
big city to go like go move back to your
country like you you like take over your
uncle's dead uncle's bakery and then you
go with your homeboy, you know,
whatever.
>> Yeah. And and but even Hallmark, I must
say, as much as it has a huge Christian
audience, even Hallmark is really
treading on dangerous ground,
introducing more magic and spiritualism
and speaking to the dead and ghosts and
all that kind of stuff.
>> You know, eventually it will all go that
way. You know, it starts off good,
starts off kosher. This is better for my
family.
>> But eventually the movie starts, oh, now
he start using the Lord's name in vain.
>> And then all these other themes come
together.
>> They're introducing homosexual
characters to like the kids.
Little kids stories have this kind of
stuff in there now. So yeah, they are
relationship modeling. That's what
you're That's what you're doing.
>> That's how you're learning.
>> Exactly.
>> So we're going to talk more about
relationships and social media
>> and videos and etc.
>> Mhm.
>> So must I start and tell you about them?
>> Let's do it.
>> Okay. So there,
>> let me first give you the foundation as
to why I went and studied this.
>> So my wife and I, we married just about
15 years now.
>> And how the Lord brought us together was
amazing.
>> Mhm. I was an Adventist Christian for
about four years.
>> And then just this one day I had the
strong impression, God wants to give me
a wife. The impression was just so
strong.
>> The next morning I opened up my Bible
and I read Proverbs chapter 5. You shall
be blessed with the wife of your youth.
>> I wrote it down. I wrote down the date
in front of my Bible because it was
really a spiritual experience of God
because I didn't think about those
things because Jesus is coming.
>> There's no time for marriage. You know,
that was my mindset at that moment.
>> I haven't met Chantel at that moment
yet. She received Bible studies during
this time. Didn't know she existed. Then
the first time I saw was a couple of
months later. She gave her testimony in
a church. She was diagnosed with lupus
and autoimmune disease. She found the
health message, followed it, and God
cured her.
>> Wow.
>> So, I did an interview with her for
television for a Christian TV station
that we were running. Mhm.
>> And the sparks weren't flying. But a
couple of months later, we started
talking more and I really felt attracted
to her and I asked God, "Is she the
one?"
>> The next morning, I read in Malachi,
different part of the Bible, "You shall
be blessed with the wife of your youth."
Same verse.
>> Wow.
>> Different part of the Bible.
>> So I asked her, "Can I phone you?"
>> She's like, "Okay." First I wanted to
come go and visit, but she wasn't there
at where we stayed. So I phoned her and
we chatted. And that weekend I was
preaching and she came to church and I
really felt good. You know this blonde
sitting in the audience because I'm
preaching that was a different feeling.
So I had to do filming for 3 weeks far
away from where we stayed. And while I
was there phoning her every night and
during this time we're really
connecting. And I said to her the one
evening, I want to tell you when I get
back home what the Lord showed me last
year on the 3rd of September. I remember
I wrote it down in my Bible.
>> Mhm.
>> And then you I fasted for seven days.
Another three days I prayed and fasted
making sure who is this right one. You
know if you
>> marry the right one marriage can be
hard.
>> You know women haven't realized what the
key to a successful marriage is yet. You
know just listen to your husband and all
will be well.
>> I was like where are you going with
this?
>> Yeah. I was like I was like wow this is
a new uh perspective.
>> He's like looking at me. And I'm like,
uh,
>> but unfortunately that that is not the
way it raises the joke, obviously. So,
he's seen if we're listening.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, if you marry the right one, marriage
can be hard. It's hard work, but it's
the greatest blessing on earth.
>> God gave it right there in the Garden of
Eden. But if you marry the wrong one,
>> then hell has come. Yep.
>> Preach. So, I was I was
>> Sorry, I didn't mean I didn't write it
the wrong way. There's no hell in my
home. I could see how that could be that
way. I married the right one.
>> So, so I I was fasting. and I was
praying. So what I said to her, what she
her response blew my mind.
>> So I said to her, I want to show you
when I'm home what the Lord showed me on
3rd of September last year before you
exist. I knew you existed.
>> And she responded, "Oh, my birthday is
on the 3rd of September."
>> And I'm sitting there,
>> wow,
>> out of 365 days of the year, God chose
her birthday.
>> Wow.
>> To tell me, I'm going to give you a why.
We were married within 6 months.
>> Wow. and we've been in ministry,
full-time ministry together for 15
years.
>> Praise the Lord.
>> So, it's like this almost like this
fairy tale coming together. You know,
God is in it.
>> But 6 months into it,
>> it's like who's going to strangle the
other one first? You know, what's going
on? So, we learned a lot through the
years and we grew together. We are
amazing together. She's amazing.
>> But we had these arguments
where we we just so hard on each other
that I couldn't understand. you know the
ones you don't want the pastor to see
>> and I was going to God I was like Lord
why are we struggling when we have
arguments we amazing the rest of the
time it's just when we have
disagreements
>> and then the Lord impressed me on my
knees the one morning go back to what
someone showed you when we did a seminar
in different province of South Africa
>> and he told me about the four
temperaments and I thought it was
interesting but didn't go any further
>> so I bought books
>> I studied online I did all the study I
was like now I finally understand. I can
show I'll show you just now who's
supposed to who marry who.
>> And we're not supposed to marry each
other in the worldly sense. But in God's
eyes, he can put any two people together
as long as they're not unequally
>> yolked.
>> We're like a cat and a dog
>> in the same house.
>> Mhm.
>> That's our temperaments.
>> Same with if the parent has my wife's
temperament and the child has mine, they
are clashing
>> through all the audiences everywhere we
go. It is the same thing over and over
again
>> because we what we just need to
understand is I'm not placing people in
a box.
>> We all have the same foundation. The
creator god.
>> Mhm.
>> So everyone that's got my temperaments
got the same foundation. But my home
life, my sibling, my culture, everything
shapes my personality.
>> Hence that makes me unique
>> and still different yet we have the same
foundation.
>> So I studied these things. I finally
understood her. She understood me. And
then I was like, "But Lord, if this is
in your genes," I had a research
scientist doing the research for me. If
this is in your genes, meaning you're
born with it, you receive it from your
parents. You cannot switch it on. You
cannot switch it off. Your temperament,
according to Andrews University, makes
up your character.
>> Mhm.
>> That means we must have received it from
God.
>> Mhm.
>> Because if I received it from my
parents, they received it from Noah. And
Noah received it from Adam. Luke says
Adam was the son of God. M
>> so meaning we received it from God then
the Bible must be saturated with this
stuff. Well
>> it makes sense to me that God would do
something like that because if there was
just infinite varieties of everything
right then you could I don't know
hypothetically say God you messed up on
mine. I didn't get one of these things
like everybody else over here. So God
maybe I don't know this what I'm
thinking in my head. He might have just
said here's four categories but all your
experiences and your choices will then
begin to shape how that person turns
out. Yes. Makes you unique. It makes you
you.
>> So I studied the Bible. I was like, "Wo,
the Bible is saturated. Four
temperaments, four gospels, four living
creatures. God, only this one was
amazing. I've never seen it before."
>> Studying the one morning at 5:00
studying these things. I'm like, "Lord,
show me. Show me." And he just flashes
it into my mind. Reneer, I've only
changed names four times in the Bible.
>> Go and study those four people. When I
studied those four people with the
temperament background, I was like,
"Whoa,
>> God changed their names based upon their
temperament when he worked on it."
>> Interesting.
>> And that's how he will prepare us for
the end based upon our temperament.
>> Wait, wait, who are they? I know it's
Jacob, Israel.
>> Yes.
>> What other ones?
>> So, it's Abraham. Abraham,
>> Abraham to Abraham, Sarai to Sarah, and
Simon to Peter.
>> That's right.
>> So, normally people say Saul to Paul,
but his name was never changed by God. I
had to study it myself. Um, Saul was his
Hebrew name. Paul was his Greek name.
>> So, he was still Saul after he was
converted because there's a story in
Acts where the Holy Spirit says to the
disciples, "Take Saul and Barnabas for
the work that I've called them to do."
So, he's still Saul afterwards. It's
just a Hebrew name.
>> Why Why would they change this one
letter like that? You know, it's kind
>> Your names meant a lot more back then
than what it does today, depending upon
your culture. So obviously it's a
culture thing
>> and the fascinating thing the devil
changed names four times in the Bible.
>> Shadrach, Meshach, and Abednego.
>> Yes.
>> And let's see who else. Daniel.
>> Daniel. Yeah, that's right.
>> All four of them he changed their names.
But we will look at it now just to give
you some meaning and context. Once I've
explained the temperaments, you would
see he actually changed the names based
upon the temperament. So So let's get
into the I'm just going to summarize the
four. So on the screen the viewers can
see that it's the collerics the Mr. and
Mrs. control. So the scientific names
the collerics the sanguins the
melancholics and the flegmatics. I like
to focus on the colors.
>> So I'm going to use the colors red for
caleric yellow for sanguin blue for
melancholic and green for flegmatic. So
the reds these are Mr. and Mrs. Control.
They in charge.
That's me. I'm 80% red. M.
>> Now, everyone is born with a strong one
and then a secondary one.
>> Sanguin is Mr. and Mrs. Fun. They're all
about fun in life. They don't go
definitely Scotty without a
>> yellow.
>> Keith is blue. I don't actually don't
know what I am. I would think between
green and yellow. I don't know.
>> And then so yellow's my second one.
That's why I'll make a joke about you
know wives haven't learned.
>> Then melancholics. That's Mr. and Mrs.
Perfect. That's the blues. That's my
wife. So she's 90% blue, very high blue.
>> So
>> the greens are the flegmatics, Mr. and
Mrs. Peacemakers. So these are the
peaceful, quiet, shy people of the
world.
>> Now the reds normally marry the greens.
>> And the yellows marry the blues.
>> Nine out of 10 times when my audience is
in front of me, the wife will come to
me, I'm this. Then I say, okay, your
husband is that. Then she's like, yes.
>> But Shantel and I,
>> it's a red and blue together. M and that
is not compatible.
>> Oh yeah. And that's why we argued
because both of them have no problem
with conflict.
>> If if I were to take each of the four
temperaments and look into their
conflict chamber of their brains, the
reds have two items in their conflict
room. It's boxing gloves.
>> The yellows, they don't have a conflict
room
>> because they avoid it. They make a joke.
Oh, why are you so serious? Come on,
let's not go. So, let's not get upset
about this thing. The Blues, their
conflict room, they've got a filing
cabinet. They can take out that file and
say 2017
9:00 in the morning, you wore a red
shirt and you said they remember all
your fault. And then their way of
telling you that they love you is to
tell you what's wrong with you. This
needs to change. This needs to change.
This needs to change. In the beginning,
you know, I couldn't step left and my
wife was like, "That hurt. Stop doing
that." Then I step right. She's like,
"That hurt. stop doing that. I'm like,
Lord, can I do anything right?
>> This is an episode I'm going to make my
wife watch.
>> So, if you're a yellow, the chances that
your wife is a blue is very high.
>> Absolutely.
>> Is your wife yellow? Are you You're blue
probably, right? I'm just guessing.
>> I am I am blue. Actually, this is a very
interesting discussion because
>> from an outward perspective, I'm blue.
>> Yeah. But the way I think is more red.
But I don't express that because I know
there's a lot of those red
characteristics that I don't think are
appropriate
>> for certain times and places.
>> Yes.
>> So when I'm thinking about how would I
handle a situation, I often think red,
but I temper it with the blue.
>> Interesting.
>> And my wife is actually green.
>> She's green.
>> Okay.
>> I can see that. Yeah,
>> I'm yellow. And I would say that I'm
kind of a little bit like that, too. But
my mind sometimes thinks in the green.
>> So it's like, you know, I'm always kind
of trying to look for like how do we
solve this and make it diplomatic? Yeah.
Make everybody happy. How does everybody
>> Because you're the life of the party.
You want everybody at the party to be
happy.
>> No, don't leave the party.
>> Yeah. So those are the four
personalities. And my wife's second one
is is green flegmatic. So she always
thinks of others. Being a blue green,
she always thinks about others. Very
considerate person. They are put on this
earth, the blues and the greens to show
us how to love people.
>> Where the reds and the yellows are shown
how to get stuff done and have fun.
>> Mhm.
>> So those are the four temperaments. I I
can just for the viewers sake, I just
summarize in a couple of words each
because they might say, "Yeah, I can see
myself, but I'm not sure yet." It's
mostly it's the greens that say, "I
don't know."
>> I don't know.
>> It's one of their sayings. It's in my
slides. It's in one of their weaknesses
is to say, "I don't know."
That's my son's go-to response.
>> So,
so the red summarize they're good at
business. They're quick thinkers. They
take charge. They're determined,
dominant, problem solvers, outgoing.
They exude confidence. They weaknesses,
they're aggressive, controlling,
overbearing, intolerant, impatient,
rude, inconsiderate, bossy, insensitive,
easily upset. The yellows, they're
convincing. They can sell ice to an ice
to eske. you know, they they can just
sell anything to anyone. They're
enthusiastic. They're optimistic.
They're sociable. They plan life around
people.
>> Mhm.
>> They're generous. They talkative. They
relax. They always have new ideas.
They're just not the ones to live those
ideas out. You need a blue or a red to
get it done.
>> Not this is like the point office is
played out at this show.
>> Their weaknesses, they do too much.
They're impatient. They late a lot
because they're talking to everyone
else.
>> If I if I could drop this mic,
>> talk to everyone. Okay, can I just cut
in here real quick? We went to a
conference recently and like we had a
running joke that Keith and I were at
the booth and like Scotty's gone.
Squirrel, squirrel. He's talking to
someone. Talking to someone.
>> I was making deals, guys.
>> He's selling everything to everyone. He
was selling it.
>> So funny.
>> Do you need some ice? Seriously.
>> So, they don't finish tasks. They're
easily bored. the impulsive,
undisiplined. You know, if if you have a
cupboard in your room for your clothing,
doesn't necessarily mean the clothing
must be inside of the cupboard. The
floor works,
>> the bathroom.
>> I feel like I'm not even wearing any
clothing right now.
>> I would not say that about him because
he he likes things put away.
>> Well, that's only because I'm going to
get beat if I don't.
>> These these are percentages and
ingredients. They're not all generally
100%.
>> So, what I'm say So, let me explain this
way. I'm explaining the temperament is
100%.
>> Your second one many times
>> levels it out that okay that's not me
that's not me and obviously we've
learned we've grown etc. So not
everything you might say yes I'm yellow
and some of the things I read like but
that's not me that's totally fine
>> totally 100% like I'm also yellow but I
put my clothes in the cupboard. I'm
talking more about the kid here.
>> You know, if you take the shower, the
the floor works too, you know, clothing.
And if it goes into the cupboard,
>> doesn't have to be folded because I can
close the door, you know.
>> Okay. The blues, they are precise. They
are systematic. They're analytical. So,
they ask questions. Sometimes you feel
like you're being interrogated.
>> It's like, you know, why have I done
something wrong? You know, why do you
ask all these questions? But they're
building the puzzle in their mind. This
is remember like Abraham in the Bible
he's a blue he was a blue
>> nice
>> when
>> who's mine
>> when when Sarah so when
>> so when um Sodom and Gomorrah what did
Abraham do
>> he went
>> if they were 45 if they were 40 if they
were 35 he's analytical so he's trying
to understand God's character by asking
questions
>> if it was a red if it was Peter standing
next to Jesus and Jesus said I'm
destroying Sodom and Gomorrah Peter
would say are
burn it and are you destroying lot? Yes
or no?
>> Let's get to the bottom line. You just
tell me the bottom line.
>> So blues, the analytical, they ask
questions. So I I choose my times when
I'm giving my wife some form of
information because I know she wants the
details.
>> And if I'm a red and I'm a man, so I've
got 500 words for the day, you know,
then I'm done.
>> Except for a show like this.
>> When I talk about these things, I get
excited. So she's going to ask me
questions. So I need to choose when I
tell her this when I'm able to give her
the details. So normally when we eat
something because then my yellow is
like, "Oh, this is nice. Let's eat
together." Happy.
>> Yeah. You got to pick your moment.
>> So they're detail orientated. They're
encouragers. They're careful. They're
considerate. They're deep thinkers. They
plan ahead. They're organized.
>> But their weaknesses, they're stuffy.
They're cold. They're critical,
sensitive, indecisive, reserved,
expressive, can see the glass half
empty, exacting, and they worry about
progress. you know, are we moving
forward?
>> Mhm.
>> Then the greens, their strengths,
they're very reliable. These people will
always pitch up. They'll always have
your back. They're considerate. They're
sharing. They're loyal. They're patient.
They're very calm. When you freaking
out, they calm.
>> They're supportive. They're easygoing,
sincere, and consistent. Do the same
thing over and over again. Very good at
that repetitive task. But they're the
most stubborn people in the world.
>> Let's go and visit. I'm not going. And
there's nothing that you can say that
will change their mind.
>> Take a donkey. Yes, exactly. They're
cautious. They withdrawn.
>> They're easily used by other people
because
>> they don't talk back. They don't speak
up for themselves.
>> They're resistant to chains. They can
come over lazy. You know, TV watching is
very high on the list in video games.
>> They're always too tired. Are we going
to do something tonight? No, I'm just
too tired. But you're on holiday. Yeah,
but I'm tired. You know, just always
tired.
>> They procrastinate. I will still do it
and easily distracted.
>> I'm going tell you one story about this
one. So we're doing this seminar at a
church. We have potluck afterwards. And
the wife comes and s a wife comes sits
next to me. Her husband is across the
room. He is a green blue. And she says,
"I want to tell you something about
being distracted."
One day her her husband was working
outside and he needed help. So he called
his wife. His wife came and she had to
hold a log while he's busy. Then he
remembered he need a certain tool for
this job. So he leaves. I verified the
fact he was sitting there. She's sitting
next to me.
>> An hour later,
>> she's still holding the log.
>> She's still holding the log.
>> Give that girl.
>> Evidently,
finally, she said, "I'm leaving this log
going to look for her husband. He's
doing something else.
>> He forgot.
>> This does sound like me at home."
>> So, they get distracted so easily. I
want to give you
>> That's like the needle to the pole, man.
>> I think I'm like kind of blue and green
because I'm hyperfocused at work. Like
when I'm in the zone, I'm in it and I'm
like super organized and everything. At
home, I'm the opposite. My husband will
tell me I'm like washing dishes and then
all of a sudden I'm like, "Oh, the the
washing machine is beeping." And I'm
start folding the laundry and he was
like,
>> "The dishes."
>> Exactly. Yeah.
>> So,
so those that's basically a summary. And
many times people at work is this one
>> more red at work. Like my mom, she's red
at work but green in her relationships.
M
>> so people use her you know there was
this one lady that will come to her
house every morning at 7 knowing that my
parents are eating breakfast and she
doesn't have a lot of money so she's
here now to eat their food
>> day after day after day then I'll go
visit my parents and my dad would say
yeah this lady comes every day we're
still in our pajamas and she eats our
food so I'm like dad say something yeah
I should say something I go 6 months
later still haven't said something still
haven't done anything but let give you a
couple one example. Let's say driving
>> or let's let's rather look at studying.
>> This is going to be a bad conversation.
>> Let's say let's say studying for the for
the younger audience, you know, how do
you approach your studies?
>> The reds, they wait till the day before
the exam to study because they work the
best under pressure. That's the way I
studied. I surfed during the mornings,
go and study in the evening for your
exam the next day.
>> I'm not saying it's right. I'm saying
that's how the brain works. Mhm.
>> The blue personalities, they prepare for
grade 12 when they're like in elementary
school.
>> These people are super prepared.
>> They find security in being prepared
>> knowing the plan.
>> So these are the kumla students. These
are the students that gets A's and if
they get 95% it's the 5% they didn't get
that bothers them.
>> Why did I get it wrong? What did I not
get with the five?
>> The green personalities they have a
desire to study.
But while the books are open and the
butterfly flies past the window or that
person walks past the door, they get
distracted
>> and then they freak out the day before
the exam. Study through the night and if
they wake up because they love sleeping,
>> they will make the exam on time and
still do well. The yellows study after
the exams because it's boring to study.
>> I study while I'm doing the exam.
>> So they they studying is not their, you
know, spreadsheets. It's not their
favorite thing in the world. Give them
people.
>> Yeah.
>> So, driving the reds for what is the
fastest way to get from point A to Z.
That's the reds. The yellows
>> like the nice cars, new cars, you know,
speed. That's what they like. The blues,
they keep to the rules.
>> 80 mph, we driving 79 miles per hour. We
are not breaking the rules.
>> I like that. If the if there's a a sign
that says don't make a U-turn,
>> they will not make a U-turn. For the
reds and the yellows, when they see the
sign, don't make a U-turn, that's just
it's just decoration.
>> Just be safe.
>> It's just to make the road look nice.
>> Suggestion.
>> Yeah.
>> It's just a suggestion, though. But if
they want to get to point A to B and the
shortest route is the U-turn, they will
make it.
>> That's funny.
>> I do that all the time at Walmart.
>> The green personalities, they're the
slowest drivers in the world. They're
just not in a hurry. So if the husband
is green, the wife is red, the wife will
drive. The wife's like, "Husband, you
sit there. We're never going to get
there. Let me drive." About two years
ago, my wife always wanted the big
washing machine. And I had a small one
that I received as a donation. You know,
starting in ministry, you don't always
have the funds.
>> And about two years ago, I could buy
this big one, the biggest and best one
in a store in South Africa. Mhm.
>> And I felt so proud as a man that here's
my wife here.
>> Here's that washing machine. As I read,
I walk to the washing machine, press
that button, you press that button, it
works.
>> What does she do? What does she do?
Where's the manual? Where's the manual?
You see what is how can I get the best
out of this? And she would read the
whole manual
>> where I don't touch the manual. I am the
manual.
>> That's how the red that I'm not saying
it's right. I'm just saying that's how
the mind works. The yellow go
>> use that one.
They have the manual.
>> The yellow goes to the shop. They come
back with the washing machine and a
microwave and an air fryer and this and
that. Say, "Honey, I got a few extra
things. Don't worry, we get money again
at the end of the month." The blue
personalities,
the as I said, they want to see the
manual of the washing machine. And the
green personalities, they still standing
in the shop.
>> Which one?
>> They can't decide which one. That's why
they marry the red. So the rate can just
say just take that one please.
>> That's me if I have to shop for tires
for a car
>> like and I am currently and it's taking
me weeks
>> to figure out which tires I want to get
>> because I'm looking at all the details
on the tire, the price, where they're
at, what benefits do they offer. And
almost every major purchase I wind up
making, I have to build a spreadsheet to
help me make a decision.
>> That's it's the analytical mind.
>> My wife doesn't like it when I go food
shopping. She actually rarely asks me to
go. I come home essentials. Yeah. Cart
full of stuff.
>> Extra stuff. Oh, this looks winds. I
mean, we needed a windmill.
>> Especially when you're hungry, it's even
worse. Then you're like, "Okay, this
looks nice. This looks nice."
>> Okay. So, are we going to jump into the
Bible? Let's do it.
>> Just jump into the Bible, then jump into
how these personalities or temperaments
approach movies.
>> So, the four temperaments and there are
four gospels. The Gospel of Matthew. I'm
just giving you summaries from what
someone like Mark Finley says about the
gospel and you tell me who they
summarizing.
>> So Mark Finley says the gospel of
Matthew is precise, exact, accurate.
>> Summarizing Keith, isn't it?
>> Yeah. Blue.
>> It's the blue personality.
>> The gospel of Matthew is they says the
most detailed gospel. The Jesus is a
teacher and blues are excellent
teachers. M
>> it's also the only box gospel that where
Jesus says be perfect like my father in
heaven is perfect.
>> The blues are the perfectionists.
>> He he noticed that
>> it's it's for everyone
>> but it really resonates with the blue
temperament. Remember how I told you how
blues tell you they love you
>> should tell you what's wrong with you.
>> Jesus dedicates an entire chapter to
tell the Pharisees and Sadducees what's
wrong with them. Matthew chapter 23 23
we call it the woe chapter. Woe to you
because this is wrong. This is wrong.
This is wrong. So, it's pretty normal
for blues to tell you what's wrong with
you.
>> So, the Gospel of Matthew is Jesus
showing us what a perfect blue looks
like.
>> So, can I just guess?
>> I would think Mark is red.
>> Yes. Correct.
>> And I think that John is green
>> with least yellow with Mark. Oh, sorry.
Luke. Yes.
>> Well done. You're 100% correct. Look at
what they say about Mark. It's
chronological, but listen to this.
shortest vigorous Jesus a man of action
fast moving.
>> Yep.
>> That's their words, not my words.
>> I'm like, thank you for summing
authorizing the red personality.
>> So, it doesn't even start with Jesus as
a baby in the major.
>> It just start with him with his work in
ministry. And reds are all about work.
>> It's called the action gospel, too.
>> Yes. That's why reds many times are
workaholics because they work too much.
>> They don't have God showed me this early
in my marriage. M
>> this is how many hours you work per day.
Treat your wife like a queen and I will
use you. If you can't do that, he
doesn't take care of his own. Cannot
take care of God's church.
>> The gospel of Luke, humanity of Jesus,
Jesus compassionate, historical
reliability, but social
>> and it's more of a story. And man,
yellows love to tell stories
>> many times. Not their story, but they
telling stories.
>> Have you heard? Have you seen? So they
love stories.
>> Did you watch this YouTube video?
YouTube is a like a crack for us.
>> I think just a couple days ago you
texted me and Keith into a group chat
with some random video about chat GPT
and I'm like okay
>> don't know what that is.
>> It's like you come across some amazing
piece of information. You're like
everyone needs to know this. So I just
blast it out to a bunch of people.
>> Then greens John Jesus son of God family
gospel. That's the key.
>> This is the gospel where Jesus talks
about his father and the holy spirit all
the time. And the reason why I also
thought green for John is because
>> I'm guessing greens are people who like
to tell more of a story.
>> Yes.
>> And this is very much more written as a
story.
>> It's written as a story. Jesus very
compassionate. The woman at the well et
no woe chapter, you know, telling
peacemaker.
>> He's the peacemaker. So, and it's it's
more the focus that Jesus focuses on his
father and the holy spirit. That's the
gospel where you read about it. I'm not
necess ne necessarily saying that all of
these gospel writers were these colors,
but it's how they portray Jesus.
>> Yeah.
>> So, if you're a red,
>> Mark is your gospel to show you what a
perfect red looks like.
>> If you're a blue, then it's Matthew. If
you're green, it's John. If you're
yellow, it's Luke. Why do I say this?
Because some people ask the question,
shouldn't we be 25 of each? And the
answer is no. Mhm.
>> Otherwise, it wouldn't have been that
when we study people that everyone has a
strong one and a secondary one.
Secondly, when I look at the four name
changes, all of those people when Jesus
was done with them changing their name,
meaning they're ready for heaven,
>> they're still the same person.
>> They still them. Because if they have to
change to someone else,
>> it means Jesus made a mistake in the
first place when he created them.
>> Right?
>> If he made me a red, now I need to blue
need to be a blue. means he made a
mistake
>> and he doesn't make mistakes. It's sin
that brought weaknesses and how does
this work in a spiritual context? Jesus
wants to sanctify our strengths because
strengths without him can make you adolf
Hitler.
>> So he wants to sanctify our strengths
and he wants to give us victory over our
weaknesses.
>> Right?
>> That's the point. That's the gospel. In
a very inspiring book called Christ's
object lessons,
>> the writer, the author writes about the
parables of Jesus. And the parable where
it talks about the leaven coming from
the outside into the dough and bringing
in the conversion.
>> It's the only place in the Bible where
leaven represents the grace of God. The
rest of the time it's sin. Yep. The
yeast.
>> And this writer writes that in this
context is about character development.
The grace of God coming from the outside
transforming us back into the image of
God. In that chapter, it says, and I'm
quoting, God does not give us new
faculties in the context of character.
He sanctifies the old ones.
>> So he doesn't come and make you into
someone you're not. You're still you,
>> right?
>> He didn't make a mistake.
>> And that's he sanctifies us.
>> That's a profound thought because, you
know, if if if the world right now is
basically saying, "I am this. God made
me like this."
>> There's a bit of truth in there, but
just bent in a way of like you're you're
you're you're still responsible to to to
adhere to the principles that God is
asking you to. But God making you. He's
not trying to completely make you into
something you're not.
>> I think the biggest lie that we have in
that is is, you know, Lady Gaga song.
And I really believe that music is also
a form of propaganda in a lot of ways.
You know, a lot of like sharing your
worldview, your morality with people
through your music, your movies, etc.
Um, but she sings born this way. you
know, that's very much adop adopted by
the LGBTQ community. But everybody who
hears this over and over and over when
you're shopping at Walmart or whatever
you do, it's that message like you can't
change, just stay who you are and stay
put. When God wants to transform our
lives, he wants to change us and set us
free from sin
>> and be reborn. And so, you know, it's
interesting that the world pushes that.
Satan is always telling part of the go
part of the story and he just leaves out
the details, right? He doesn't he shy
away from you need a savior, I'll just
give you a different savior, you It's
like he replaces it.
>> So, how do you then, this is where my my
mind goes, how do you then explain
what Jesus was like? M
>> because if Jesus was born on this earth
with a particular
percentage across the board of these
four different personality types and
he's not let's say he's not 25% in each
category
>> then
the way he was
seems like I don't know I'm just
thinking through it and it seems like he
was perfectly balanced in his thinking
in his life the way he treated other
people the way he handled situations
and you would think that's the ultimate
model for us to be.
>> Yes.
>> So, how do you
explain that along with God making
people the way they are? Because it
seems like
>> because I hear what you're saying, God
made us who we are, but it seems like we
are
>> imbalanced in our
>> extremity. Like if I'm a red,
>> I probably God probably needs I mean
probably needs to tone that dial that
back. Yes.
>> Because I I I either me or sin in me
amplifies the red to an extreme that's
unhealthy.
>> Yes. The weaknesses.
>> So
>> how does that
>> So So I believe when I look at the
gospels, I mean why four gospels?
>> Yeah.
>> Why not just one? Why tell the cross
story four times?
>> It needs to be needs to appeal to
different kinds of people. He's
appealing to all four of the
temperaments.
>> Now, I believe Jesus was all of them. I
don't believe he was just one strong one
and secondary one because
>> when he and I know some people going to
say, "But didn't he take our nature?"
That means he has to be have only one
strong one, a secondary one.
>> I believe he took our fallen nature as
when it comes to being able to be
tempted, etc. But he needed to show us
what we would look like perfectly.
>> Mhm.
>> In each of the four gospels. So he lived
out all four.
>> Mhm.
>> For us to see, okay, this is what a a
sanctified green looks like. This is
what a sanctified red looks like.
>> And that's why I believe it brings the
balance in the thinking of yes, God
wants us to be in his image. Create the
way he created us just without sin. Sin
is the issue.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's what he wants to take out of
our hearts. So when he transforms us, he
aligns our thoughts, our feelings, and
our will with his.
>> Yeah. I I I see what you're saying
though. But I think I think I kind of
see it like you're seeing that that we
are made in God's image and he has all
the four temperaments.
>> But just like you're made in God, God's
image and I am. I'm not a male.
>> Yes.
>> You're not a female. I can't be both
male and female in order to be complete
image of God. Do you see what I mean?
>> That's interesting. That's
>> Let's not go down.
>> Anyway, but these do you see my point?
>> Yeah, I was tracking. But but the the in
some ways a counterargument to that is
you aren't complete. This is what some
people would say until you find that
other person and you become one that you
are more in God's image. Because that's
what Adam did with Eve. It's like he
wasn't complete until he had Eve. They
became one and now it's more of a
complete image with God. And I'm not,
you know, I understand there are people
who are single, there are people who are
>> widowed there, and I'm not saying you
can't be a complete person by yourself,
but
>> it it in some ways, here we go with the
blue personality. In some ways it
appears to be illogical to say God would
not want us to be perfectly balanced in
those areas
>> because if he is and we're supposed to
be molded after his image and likeness,
>> then it seems that what we have is
imbalanced because of sin or environment
or combination of all of that. and that
those things need to be dialed back in
their extremity and brought back to more
more balance and percentage and that
they would the different parts would be
expressed in different places and
situations like Jesus did where
um where it would be appropriate
>> but then how do you have everyone having
unique personalities still like because
then everybody kind of becomes the same
right
>> and that makes sense as well
can I explain I understand exactly what
you're saying and where you're going
>> I believe I can be a perfectly balanced
red.
>> Mhm.
>> For through Jesus.
>> I don't need to be a different color.
I'm I'm very satisfied being a red
>> and happy but in Jesus.
>> Mhm.
>> Giving my self-confidence over to him
etc.
>> So I can and you can everyone can be
balanced in who they are and you can
acquire strengths of others without it
being innate without it being your
default setting. Like for instance, when
I did video editing for the TV channel
back then, my red is get this one done
so I can get over to the next one.
>> So I just did the one after the other.
Now my wife is on some of the programs
and I think I can just edit that way.
She's like, "No, you edit, you watch
this thing through. I'm going to watch
it through. We're going to go back." And
I'm like, "But that's torture.
>> Do I actually have to watch the whole
thing again?"
So I had to acquire a strength of hers
being more thorough
>> because I had to do stuff over and over
again because I made mistakes.
>> Yeah.
>> But am I blue? No. Have I acquired it?
Yes. Have I acquired by watching her,
observing her to be more considerate
towards other people? Yes. Am I
naturally considerate? No.
>> Yeah.
>> But because I know these things, I then
ask Jesus, help me in the moment to be
more considerate, to be more tolerant.
And it's it's that knowledge. The Bible
says without knowledge we are destroyed.
>> Yeah.
>> You know with a lack of knowledge. But
with knowledge I can actually now apply
these principles with the health of
Jesus and still be a balanced red.
>> You also you need to understand someone
else. And so if you have a little bit of
that inside of you then it makes it a
whole lot more easy for me to kind of
try to see where you're coming from. And
I imagine that like you know marriage is
is not necessarily designed to make you
happy or I should say the goal is not
just straight happiness. And the reason
I'm saying that is is because what if
it's unhappy?
>> What if it's like that if you make that
your goal then then that thing is is if
it doesn't go right your marriage falls
apart.
>> It's it's to make you more holy.
>> Yes. So to rub somebody that sees things
differently which may frustrate the
living um yeah just between the two of
you. I could see that God designed the
thing to say here I'm going to I'm going
to confront you with some things that
you need to work on and vice versa. I
think there's things that each one of us
bring to the table but the other person
>> sees that differently than we do. So, I
I think we're probably coming from
somewhat of the same place because as I
hear you talk, you know, the red is
acquiring other things to to balance it
out if it's in the extreme. And so I
kind of look at it like, okay, if I have
um let's say I have a a cup and it's
full of um let's say red Kool-Aid
>> and it's only got red Kool-Aid in it.
Well, to balance that out, I am going to
pour in some green Kool-Aid and some
yellow Kool-Aid and some blue Kool-Aid,
>> right? And so now that extremity and red
Kool-Aid becomes closer
to that 25%.
>> Yes.
>> It's not that it is 25% but it's going
to come closer to that. And that's then
I guess in
>> thinking about it like logically,
analytically like it's moving more that
way because that's how Jesus was. And
we, you know, we're not going to be that
maybe even perfect 25%
>> balance because we're going to be unique
people. But character perfection is
moving us that way to be more like him.
Yes.
>> But we're not saying
>> I don't think we're saying
>> I'm red and all I need to do is just
purify the red so that it's more red.
>> Right. because you're acquiring other
parts of these
>> um personalities
uh traits
>> because you know if it's only red
>> well then you're going to exhibit more
of those undesirable red characteristics
that need to be
>> you you need some of the others
>> you need some of
>> to overcome the weaknesses of the red
but you're still a red
>> I think the designer of music God
>> illustrates this idea Right? I mean, you
can play something with the same
instruments, but it's interesting when
everybody brings their flavor and their
sound together and then this something
beautiful happens with that. And the
same thing's happening with our
relationships, I believe, too. I think
if everybody was the same,
>> I don't know, you you'd probably be a
little bit, you know, like, okay, I've
seen this before. But the fact that
we're all kind of unique and different
and these combinations of you're a
little bit more of this and that, it's
like it opens it up for creativity and
variety which you see in God's creation.
>> If we as a family are in a hurry, we
always travel together.
>> So look, my whole family is here in the
US. We we like we have family ministry.
That's how I prefer it.
If we're about to leave, the plane is
leaving, we need to rush, and we're
about to leave the house, and either my
wife or my eldest son, who's got that
temperament, starts crying about
whatever,
>> it's really hard for me.
>> It's not time to cry.
>> It's time to get things done. It's time
to move.
>> And it's that time that Jesus then needs
to speak to my heart
>> and say, you know what, they different
and that's okay.
>> That's the main thing. We are different
and that's okay. It's for us to
>> to to make sure that we live surrendered
life to Jesus in the moment. And that's
the key. And that's one of the things my
wife talks about when we do these
seminars is she comes and she talks
about how to live a surrendered life.
Now that you know who you are, now that
you understand your weaknesses, you
know, you're more intolerant
>> and you need each other.
>> Exactly.
>> God made a symbiotic relationship
between everything. I mean the bees need
to take take the pollen and go make it
around so you can enjoy these beautiful
flowers that the human walks by and
goes, "Oh, cool." And the whole thing's
like that. Yes. Right. So if if we are
parts and bits of these and you see the
way that someone else is acting, it's
like you have these abilities to
>> I got to work together. What can I do to
help them get out of the house faster or
be more prepared or you know Exactly.
>> I have a son that that is um
>> needs a lot of time.
You you cannot tell him we're leaving in
15 minutes. He will panic.
>> You have to tell him we're leaving in an
hour. You tell him we're leaving in an
hour. This is usually what we do. Then
he he can prepare.
>> You tell him 15 minutes. Oh, it upends
his entire world and he does not know
how to.
>> So I assume he's also a blue.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh
>> so I'm green.
>> So it doesn't deal with change.
>> Don't
change is not
>> change is not his friend. is not
probably the greatest thing. I don't I'm
not sure what he is because I would say
in a lot of ways he's more like my wife
and she's great.
>> Okay.
>> But in other ways, he's probably like
me.
>> Yeah. But I I'm the type that change.
No.
>> Yeah.
>> No. Like he and I It's funny. We'll have
conversations about something. So I'm
sitting here processing the whole
conversation
>> and then when I'm when I've when it's
like, "Okay, I've made my decision."
>> It's like, "Okay, it's time to speak."
>> Yes. And then I and we talk about it and
it's like, okay.
>> And I it took me a long time to figure
out he's he's just thinking out loud.
>> And so I come back the next day, he
wants to have the conversation again.
And I'm sitting there going,
>> I thought we already decided this. Like
I've already moved on. Like why are we
talking about this? It doesn't make any
sense.
>> Yeah.
>> And then I'm sitting there thinking
like, did what I say not make any sense?
Because I said it. It made sense to me.
And why are we still talking about it? I
thought we made a decision. You see,
it's it's the difference between
introverts and extroverts.
>> When I say introvert, people think, "I
don't want people." If I say extrovert,
people think, "I want a lot of people."
But it's actually how you process your
thoughts and your feelings.
>> Introverts process their thoughts and
their feelings inward. That's why many
times they're the own worst enemy. Oh,
that was terrible. Oh, I can't believe I
said that. Why did I send that message?
And then they started to sleep at night.
Why did I, you know, when I send that
message, why didn't they not put that
heart emoticon they normally do next to
it? and they start to analyze the whole
thing and you know it's always inward
and that's why they've got an assembly
line of thoughts to choose from when
they're going to speak like my wife
would say if I say this he's going to
react that way if I say this they're
going to react that way those are the
introverts
>> the extroverts they process their
thoughts and feelings by saying it
>> so they've got a zipline between their
brain and their tongue there it is
>> so true
>> and then all the blues go like
>> why' you say that
>> why did you just say that my wife would
actually look at me and Okay, I'm going
to give you a moment to rephrase
yourself.
>> Then I want to use that one
>> now. I know I'm already in trouble. Then
I rephrase it
>> and she's like, "Why didn't you say that
in the first place?" And I'm like, "But
that is what I said in the first place."
>> Oh, why does it sound so much like my
whole
>> Because if if I go into my brain, there
is no assembly line of thoughts to
choose from.
>> The first one that came in came out.
>> True. Wow.
>> And that's why the Bible says, "Put a
guard in front of your mouth." He's
speaking to the reds and the yellows,
>> the blues, it's easy. They like, "It's
easy to think about what you say." No,
it isn't.
>> I'm always like, "Why did I tell the
mailman that?"
>> Back in there, I was like,
>> "So, let's just quickly, let me just
show you the four living creatures, four
different faces. The lion. If you study
the lion in the Bible, it's bold,
powerful, leader, brave."
>> It's the reds.
>> Mhm.
>> If you study the ox in the Bible,
servant, noble, persevering, powerful.
It's the greens. They are the servants.
>> Mhm.
>> If you study the manface, it's the
reason, wisdom, love, God's social side.
Once again, it's the yellows. Study the
eagle in the Bible. The Bible says they
are swift. They protect and they
allseeing. They see the details.
>> Those are the blues.
>> So, I'm giving you once again what
theologians say about the four living
creatures. Those are not my words.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm just showing you how they summarize
it.
>> And fascinating thing, God only gave us
four things in the Garden of Eden. It's
for everyone, but it speaks to each
personality. Genesis 1:26, I give you
dominion. All the reds go,
>> ah, that feels good.
>> Yeah,
>> I'm in charge. If you tell a green, I
give you dominion.
>> That doesn't feel so good.
>> You know, it's for everyone.
>> Sure.
>> But it speaks more to the reds. Then he
said, be fruitful and multiply. This I
tested. Are these the greens? Because
Jacob, as a green in the Bible, he had
13 children. M.
>> So I went to Greens and asked them, "If
you get married, how many children do
you want?" And this one girl
specifically said, "Man, I see my one
child playing the violin, the other
one's playing the piano, the other one's
washing the dishes, the other one's in
the garden." I'm like, "I need to pray
for your husband."
>> And we introduced her husband to her.
They are married today so far of only
one child.
>> But the point is that they are family.
>> He's red.
>> Yes, Mr.
family orientated people. The green just
like the gospel of John. You can take
the thread and run it right through the
Bible.
>> That was my wife. She wanted six kids.
>> Six kids. Exactly.
>> And you said she's green.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah.
>> Exactly. Then they want the kids.
>> Then the yellows. God said, "Of every
tree in the garden, I give you food to
eat." And all the yellows go, "Amen."
>> Their favorite part of a sermon.
>> It's gotten people in a lot of trouble
over the years.
>> Should check the stack of uh snacks
Scotty brings in. I literally cannot go
inside of a grocery store or like a a
convenience store when I'm filling up
gas. I have to actually stay outside.
>> So Keith will be very disciplined when
he goes in.
>> He's usually disciplined with his food
>> because it's he works based upon a list.
Whether he has a physical list or the
list in his head, he will go into the
shop, we buy this and this and this. It
equals the budget.
>> I'm always driving by going, "No way.
They're having a sale."
>> Yeah.
>> Going in there.
>> That's why they have sales because all
the yellows fall for it. But blues can
be emotional eaters. Just putting it out
there. If the Moses is in charge, then
they love to eat anything. So the
yellow, so the food once again is for
everyone,
>> but reds eat to get it done. We need to
go and do our job. The yellows they eat
because it's pleasure. It is
>> a social event. And then the blues, once
again, it's for everyone, but it really
speaks to the blues. When God gave Eve
to Adam, companionship,
>> blues are the people that they want to
connect with their parents, their father
or their mother. if they don't connect
with their father or their mother like a
deep relationship where the parent
actually listens to their inmost deepest
feelings because they feel very deep
>> then they will find a friend. If they
don't find a friend they will find a
boyfriend or a girlfriend. Doesn't
matter how old they are
>> you know if they 14 15 years old there's
someone that's willing to listen
>> and make them feel safe in their
emotions they will be attracted that to
that person. So once again, it's for
everyone,
>> but it really speaks to the blues. They
struggle to be in alone in that's why
the blues, let's say he's packing for a
trip for him, it means a lot if his wife
joins him in the packing.
>> Can you just help me with this? He can
do it on his own, but it's not
companionship.
>> Like my wife be like folding the
laundry. Can you just help me with this?
Not like she can't do it.
>> It's just my presence. If she works on
the talk for church, then she needs to
do a talk. I just need to sit next to
her.
>> Just need to be there.
>> Yeah.
>> And then she can do anything. She's
like, I can conquer the world just
because you are here. And I feel the
same. If she's in the audience,
>> man, then then I really love to preach.
But if she's not there, I people don't
really recognize the difference, but I
know it's different when she's not
there.
>> For for the introverts like myself, you
can be um
you can be in a room full of people and
completely alone.
>> Yes. But you can also be um but they
also don't like to be alone. Like I hate
to go home if nobody's there
>> and and people can be around all day and
I don't have to talk to them.
>> But if they're there,
>> you find comfort in that.
>> If if you were to ask my wife when were
some of the times you struggled most in
our marriage, I would I would think she
would say the three times I came to the
US on my own.
>> Mhm. because those times she doesn't
want to leave the house. She just has
the kids on her own. She doesn't want to
face people or face life. She just wants
when are you coming back?
>> Like my one trip last year to the US.
It's a it's a long flights
to get here.
>> I left the Tuesday. I left the USA on
the Sunday. I was here for like 3 days.
Went back home because I also want to be
with my family. Now that they were six
weeks,
>> we here enough time. So the blues really
that's what they long it's important to
them and we see it in Abraham whose name
was changed from Abraham to Abraham the
four name changes.
>> Now let's let's do the thread. This this
is goosebump stuff.
>> In the beginning God says I give you
companionship for everyone but the blues
as we have now agreed upon really
resonates with that. God promised
Abraham a companion in his son
>> because it fulfills the very promise and
the name change because the name change
means father of many nations and he
needs a son to fulfill his own heavenly
key.
>> Are you following me?
>> And what does God ask him to do?
>> Sacrifice him.
>> Sacrifice your companion.
>> Wow.
>> Puts it into perspective. which is
probably the hardest thing for him.
>> And then what does God show him when
he's about to sacrifice his son?
>> That there is
>> the ram.
>> Yeah.
>> Which gospel focuses the most on the
fact that Jesus said, "My God, my God,
why have you forsaken me?"
>> It's the gospel of Matthew.
>> Oh, it's Matthew.
>> It's Matthew. It's the blue gospel.
Yeah. That's the gospel that focuses
most on the fact that God, the father
and son, was separated, companionship
broken.
>> Yeah. You know, I I you think about that
in the universe, we've brought this up
on this channel before, no celestial
being has ever died
>> other than Jesus.
>> Yes.
>> And it's like he's the only one. And and
and if they've existed forever and ever
and ever and ever and ever, and it's
like never been separated,
>> that separation for the, you know, like
your wife, right? It's it's it's
torture.
>> It's torture. And we often don't don't
necessarily always talk so much about
what God was going through during that
experience
>> and that he was even willing to um allow
that to to transpire. I mean that's
that's that's crazy.
>> It's crazy. And if there's death in the
family
>> and the blue was really connected that
person they take the longest to get you
can't say get over it because they never
do.
>> Mhm. They can start living again, but it
takes the longest time for that blue to
really start living again. I saw it when
my wife's mother died unexpectedly or
they had a close relationship. And all
the reds out there would be like, "Oh,
just get over it.
>> It's been 2 years. Why are you still
crying?"
>> And it's because they don't understand a
person. This is why this information is
so important for us to how we treat
people. It gives us more grace. It gives
us a better understanding of, wow, you
know what? you're different and that's
okay. God made you in his image. Because
in the beginning when I studied these
things for the very purpose of
understanding my wife, I started using
it as a weapon.
>> Oh, you're just being a blue now. You're
just critical again. Faultf finding.
>> Unfortunately, I did those things.
>> And the one morning while on my knees,
the Lord came to me and he said to me,
just not audible voice, but his voice
came to my mind and said,
>> "If I do not accept my wife as a blue,
there's a part of him I do not accept."
>> Wow. And it hit me like here and that's
where everything changed
>> and I totally saw the thing in a
different perspective.
>> I I too have had that, you know, like
like certain personality types will will
sort of irk at my skin, you know, and
it's like I I I I find that I'm wanting
to avoid certain people for that kind of
reason. And then I think God convicted
me of that years ago and just said,
don't don't think negatively towards
them. Like find the part that like you
like about them. And I'll tell you, it
revolutionized. I I could go up to
people that I either had a problem with
or something and be fine like with it
and not be thinking about like I don't
like this person, you know, kind of a
thing. And so yeah, God God I'm sure
>> has a remedy for all of our personality
types to reconcile and you know
>> like I normally tell the story like I
give each personality a vehicle when I
explain their personalities in detail
like the rage is a bulldozer who gets
killed in the process on the way to
success doesn't matter as long as we get
there. But if Jesus is in the bulldozer,
you know, they can safely not kill
people.
>> And for the yellows, it's a jet plane.
Life is fun. It's
>> more like a flying saucer cuz it kind of
goes in all different.
>> So then I normally look at the jet plane
and I'm like, okay, the yellows
shouldn't design it. It's going to fall.
>> And then they're going to laugh and say,
"That was fun. Let's do it again."
>> The blues need to design it and it will
be perfect. The yellows will sell it and
get the best price. The reds will fly
and never make an accident. And the
greens would take care of the people on
the plane. Everyone would be happy.
>> That's awesome.
>> So, so everyone's got their role.
>> That's funny.
>> So, let's So, Abraham, as I said, he was
analytical, asking Jesus over and over
to get the picture in his mind,
companionship, and he was also
considerate. And hospitality is
important to blues. So, he washed the
angel's feet. He gave them food to eat.
>> Then Sarah, the only person in the Bible
where the word laughter is used with is
Sarah.
>> And she was the yellow. Unfortunately,
yellows make impulsive decisions. They
do things quickly and it's never their
fault. It's in my slides. It will say
they blame others. And what did Sarah
do? Impulsive decision. Take Hagar. And
then she blamed Abraham for the problem.
>> Oh boy.
>> And then she chased her away. So
unfortunately, and I believe God is
trying to paint a picture because there
are many beautiful amazing things about
yellows. If I take this guy, I put him
in a crowd of non-believers,
he will connect with every single one
and have a story to tell with them to
every single one.
>> Me as a read, I will stand there like, I
don't know what to say.
>> And I can resonate with Peter. Peter is
actually the guy that told Mark about
the gospel.
>> Mark got his info from Peter and Peter
was already
>> and Peter and it's only in Mark when
Jesus appeared with Moses and Elijah.
It's only Mark that writes after Peter
said, "Let's do the tent."
>> Then he writes because he didn't know
what to say. I was like, I can resonate.
I can say a lot now because I understand
information. But otherwise, sometimes,
you know, my wife tells me deep things
and I would lie next to her on the bed
and I say nothing.
>> And then then she turns to me. Are you
not going to say anything? Then it's too
late in any case. Then if I say
something, she looks at me, it's too
late because blues, they like two-way
conversations. You need to be a part of
it. You need to give input. You're not
just the soundboard with bouncing off.
You actually need to give input.
>> So I believe God did this for a reason
where basically if you read the Bible
about Sarah,
>> can you tell me anything positive about
her? Unfortunately,
>> there isn't anything
>> beautiful. She was beautiful and she and
she gave and she gave birth to
>> to Isaac. But the rest of the thing she
does isn't the most positive. She blames
Abraham for Hagar. She says take then
she chases Hagar away. And by the way,
the fact that she was beautiful, yellows
are extremely attracted to beautiful
people.
>> We're like bees to the flower.
>> Yes. That's why I've got a beautiful
wife. Of course, I've got yellow in me.
That's that's just the way it works.
>> So,
but listen to this. In my seminar, I
show you each person what they need most
in life.
>> The rich needs appreciation.
>> But no one wants to appreciate a bossy,
overbearing, I tell you what to do type
of person. So they don't get what they
need.
>> The blues needs acknowledgement.
Acknowledge my feelings. Understand my
world.
>> But who wants to acknowledge someone
that continually tells you what's wrong
with you?
>> So no one does it.
>> The Greens need respect. Ask me what I
think because they're not going to tell
you. You need to ask them, "What do you
think? What are your thoughts?"
>> But because they're quiet, they don't
speak up for themselves. They're the
most bullied people in the world. People
bulldoze them, use them, and walk over
them so they don't get what they need.
>> Yellows need admiration.
>> Oh, I like your new shoes.
>> You know, they they want that.
>> It it sounds terrible, but there's a
biblical way to look at it. And I'm
going to give you the example in the
name change. It's almost like look at
me, look at me, look at me. They they
you know, they ride the bicycle, dad
look, and I look at my son and I clap my
hands. That's what they they want that
admiration.
>> And God knows this because he implanted
it in us. Listen to this. Sarai
means princess.
>> Sarah means my princess.
>> Oh wow.
>> See how God changed her name in the very
need they have she has in life. While
there's not many positive things.
>> Yeah.
>> Because if you look at I do a whole
seminar on uh or whole talk on
communication
>> and each personality needs four things
in life. How you communicate with them
and Paul says we need to speak according
to their needs not our needs. M
>> and one of the lines, the first thing
the yellow needs is admiration in the
sense of liking me without me having to
change.
>> That's what they want in life.
>> Don't tell me continue. Oh, don't do
this. Why did you do that? Because they
do impulsive things. They're the ones
that when they eat, you know, doesn't
necessarily stay in the plate. It can be
on the table and everywhere else.
>> So, but people want them to change. You
need to be more like me.
>> No,
>> they them. God. It's they only need
victory over their weaknesses. So that's
Sarah. Jacob, he was a green. Jacob
changed. And the the thing that greens
hate most in life is confrontation.
>> They hate confrontation.
>> How did he flee from Laban? Hey Laban
>> in the night.
>> In the night,
>> avoiding the conflict.
>> Gone.
>> They don't speak up for themselves. So
Laban knows I can give you Leah. You're
not going to do anything.
>> Yeah. He gives him Leah.
>> That's just a crazy. Then and then he
gives them he changes his wages 10 times
to his detriment.
>> Why? He knows Jacob's not going to do
anything.
>> So what would his dad be
>> a to Laban
>> or his father-in-law?
>> Jacob's his father-in-law, he's probably
a red just bulldozers, just does what he
wants.
>> But he but he also avoided conflict with
Esau.
>> When you know these things about like
that, that just brings the Bible to life
and like you understand now people. Why
did you act like that? Why did you do
that?
>> Exactly. That's ah that's a good
perspective.
>> Going back to Sarah, you know, the
Bible, you make a good point. The Bible
doesn't have a lot of good to say, but
she is listed in Hebrews 11.
>> Exactly.
>> As those who grasp, you know, in faith
and a hold of God, she grasp a hold of
God's promise.
>> Yes.
>> Even though it was a bumpy
>> start.
>> God still changed her name, meaning she
he prepared her for heaven because
that's that's what name changes
represent.
>> So reading between the transformation,
you realize that that happened. That
transformation happened.
>> Yes.
Jacob after God changed his name meaning
he's ready for heaven he's ready for the
kingdom he's still a green the next day
he sees Esau he bows down seven times
and says Lord to the guy if Jacob was a
red
>> and God appeared to him and said I'm
appearing to Esau you don't be afraid he
would have gone up to Esau and say you
know who's with me I'm not afraid of you
that would have been the red but the
green is still bowing down still calling
him Lord still does nothing when his
eldest son took his concubine still does
nothing when his daughter was raped by
the guy from Sheckchum. Wow.
>> And that's why his sons responded and
retaliated. Now, what they did was still
wrong, but dad should have stood up and
said, "You know what?
>> What you did was wrong.
>> We're leaving."
>> You know, just something like that. And
his sons being reds among them
retaliated
>> because of it. Obviously, what they did
wasn't right.
>> So, that's Jacob. And then Peter, you
know, reds want something straight to
the point. Jesus walks up to Peter.
>> You shall no more call be S Simon but
you're not Peter. That's the first thing
he does. He changes his name and he
changes his name to Peter or Petros in
Greek which means small little pebble.
>> Mhm.
>> Matthew chapter 16,
>> Jesus asks the disciples, "Who do people
say that I am?" Some say prophet, some
say John the Baptist.
>> Who do you say that I am? Peter answers,
>> son of God.
>> You are the Christ, the living son of
God.
>> Well done, Peter. Flesh and bones has
not revealed this to flesh and blood
hasn't revealed this to you but my
father in heaven.
>> Then Jesus looks at Peter. You are Peter
and upon this rock I will build my
church.
>> You are Peter small little pebble. Upon
this rock the Greek word is patra. Jesus
pointing to himself. I will build my
church. So Jesus is telling Peter you
need to keep your eyes on me.
>> The next thing Jesus does, I give you
the keys of heaven. He's talking to
Peter. Gives him more power.
Then Jesus says, "I will be crucified
and rise again after 3 days." Peter just
acknowledged through God's power just
Jesus just told him, "Look at me." Just
gave him all power. Then he says, "I'll
be crucified and rise again." Peter goes
to him. The only among the personalities
that would have the guts to then take
Jesus apart and rebuke him. The Bible
said he rebuked Jesus.
>> Oh wow. And who's the one that's got the
the confidence to say when Jesus walking
on the water, I'll walk on the water.
Thank you. He walks on the water and
then in his self satisfaction and
confidence, he looks back at his friends
and he starts sinking.
>> Yeah. He whipped off the ear of the
>> He's the guy that whipped up the ear.
He's the guy that had the confidence. I
won't deny you.
>> But then he becomes broken.
>> Yes.
>> And then Jesus has to reaffirm his
confidence.
>> Yes. He reaffirms his confidence. And
then he became one of the most powerful
evangelists the world has ever seen. M.
>> So yeah, you can see all the name
changes, how God worked with them in the
very areas that you and I struggle with
today.
>> Amazing.
>> Okay, I think there's one more thing.
Yes, the four name changes done by the
devil. Daniel, Haniah, Michelle, and
Aariah.
>> Listen to the meaning of the words.
Daniel means God is my judge. Blues are
very,
how can I put it? This is important for
them in life is justice. You've done
something wrong, there needs to be
consequences.
>> Mhm.
>> God is my judge. That's what his name
means. Haniah, Yahweh is gracious. If
you read the Gospel of Mark, the most
famous verse in the Gospel is where
Jesus shows the reds that the son of man
came to serve,
not to be served. Reds like to be
served.
>> Aariah, Yahweh has helped. That's the ox
of the four living creatures, the
servant.
>> Michelle, who belongs to God? My
princess,
>> Sarah, my princess. Now, listen to what
the devil has done. Mhm.
>> Daniel to Belshazzer means Belle will
now protect his life. If you go back to
know, if you connect it to the four
living creatures, the eagle,
>> the eagle protects.
>> Yeah,
>> that was one of the words when you study
the Bible in the beginning where it says
Genesis chapter 1, the Holy Spirit
hovered over the waters. That word
hovered means as the eagle protects her
young.
>> So that's what the eagle represents. But
now who protects
>> bell?
>> Another god. Hananiah to Shadrach,
Yahweh is gracious to command of Aku. If
you read other books about the
personalities, they call the reds the
commanders.
>> But who is commanding now?
>> It's another God, right?
>> As a Yahweh's help to servant of Nabu.
What does the ox do? It's the servant.
>> But who do you serve? Another god.
>> And then Michelle to Mach who belongs to
God to who is as Aku is. Now you don't
belong to God anymore. You become God.
Now let's connect this to what Solomon's
I think this is the last thing I wanted
to share before we go into how they're
approaching movies.
>> Proverbs 31 11-14 in the CJB version.
There is a type of people who curse
their fathers and don't bless their
mothers.
>> Blues struggle with their parents if one
of the parents is red.
>> It's throughout this world. Doesn't
matter where I go. It's the same thing.
My wife struggled with her father. He
was a red. He was absent when she cried.
Had any emotions. Stop crying. stop
being this way. And they struggle. If
the parent is a blue and the child is
the red, they struggle. I have so many
friends like I mentioned one after the
other that there's been issues in the in
the household when the child is blue
because they are misunderstood. Why are
you crying? Why you feel so deep? Why do
you can't you just make a decision?
>> And that leads them to curse their own
fathers and mothers. M
>> if they do not allow God obviously to
work in their lives
>> then there is a type of people clean in
their own view but not cleansed from
their filth. The greens do not shout
>> they do not fight. So the red will be
shouting why are you not standing up for
yourself? Da da da. And the green will
freeze during conflict
>> in their own eyes. I'm not the problem.
>> Mhm.
>> And we do plenty of marriage counseling.
And when the husband is green, it's the
hardest to counsel
>> because they don't face their own
issues. They don't like change and
they're not the problem. The wife is the
one shouting. The wife is the one with
issues. Now, the Bible says you're clean
in your own view,
>> but inside it's not that way.
>> Mhm.
>> There is a type of people, how haughty
they look, utterly superilious. You
know, the yellows want admiration. But
this is when it's taken too far.
>> Oh, look at me. Look at me. But the way
Satan did it,
>> it was beautiful in his own sight.
>> And there is a type of people whose
teeth are like swords. Yes, their fangs
are knives. Us reds, unfortunately, with
our mouths, we hurt a lot of people.
That's what Solomon says, four types of
people. And if you look at what David
says, who will appear in the presence of
the Lord in Psalms, he mentions four
types of people. Should we connect this
now with Hollywood?
>> Yeah,
>> let's do that.
>> Let's connect it with Hollywood. Okay.
Okay. So the reds these are competitive
people. So they are driven to compete.
So they are very drawn to sports and
that's the type of area in life many
times where they are driven towards
yellows are driven by pleasure. So many
times these unfortunately the guys that
will fall into pornography and and those
type of things. The blues they're driven
by companionship. So the romance,
especially the woman, the romance and
the fantasy, the the unreal
>> companionship that's out there, the
greens, they're driven by peace. So the
television is all they need,
>> just the TV in front of them.
>> So many times they are they have a
television in the living room,
television in the dining room,
television in the kitchen, television in
the bedroom, you know, everywhere there
are televisions.
>> But when it comes to movies,
>> the reds are really attracted to action
movies. You know, action one scene to
the other. It's just action and modern
action, not old things. There must be
action.
>> So if you are drawn towards action
movies, the chances are that your red is
is very good.
>> Then the yellows, they are drawn to
comedies. Obviously, laughter, it's fun,
you know, it's light, not too deep, no
crying the whole time.
>> The blues, they are drawn more towards
fantasy, Lord of the Rings, Harry
Potter, these these things that doesn't
really exist
>> and true stories. They love true
stories. My wife loves true stories. So
that we buy these missionary books
that's just available in the US of
missionaries in the past of how they
saved people. My wife loves it. They
love she loves the truth.
>> It's an interesting contrast because on
the one hand you know something that's
absolutely true and the other hand
something completely not true at all.
>> Yeah.
>> So she loved when she was in the world
before she became a Christian she loved
the fantasy world you know the Lord of
the Rings and those type of things. She
she really liked it. So the reds when it
comes to fantasy they will be more drawn
towards action heroes
>> more to the you know the superman the
Batman it's it's not real but there's
action more that type of action
>> the greens also into fantasy and in
romance
>> that's the world they go into and some
of the men horrors
>> in the green world because they are
bullied
>> they enter a world that is really the
guy is just taking out everyone and Most
of the time it's the Greens that takes
their rifle, walks into the school and
shoots everyone.
>> Oh wow.
>> Because they will be at home watching
these movies. They're into heavy metal
music. I've got know many greens. That's
the music they listen to because it
takes them out of that reality
>> and then they play these first hand
shooter games. And then they just go and
live it out in reality. They start
shooting.
>> I think you're right. If you looked at
probably the life of the Coline kids or
the ones that shot up the school, they
were probably the ones that were the
just quiet, sit in the corner, trench
coats. Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
>> So, I'm not saying that every single one
is them, but majority, it's because
they've been bullied. I've seen also the
Greens, they are the ones that go into
karate getting the black belts,
kickboxing because they want to defend
themselves because they've been bullied
and they want, they actually have a
desire to protect people. Mhm.
>> That's actually what God put in their
hearts is to protect
>> and to so security companies many times
they're the greens pastors they're the
greens.
>> So the perversion of that then is to
destroy.
>> Is to destroy.
>> Oh that's interesting.
>> Like one of the story I'm going to tell
now is from my previous life. So it's
not that I'm not condoning this. I'm
just giving an example.
>> So my one friend he is a green yellow
>> and
we were out at a club one night. I when
I went clubbing, as soon as the alcohol
flowed, my yellow came out. So, I became
more fun. I my red aggressive side
didn't come out.
>> So, I didn't really fight. That was my
thing. But the one evening, there was
this guy that was irritating me. And I
was grabbing him like this. And when I
grabbed him, within two seconds, he was
out and I did nothing.
>> Oh, wow.
>> So, my friend was standing next to me.
He's taller. So, I was like, again, I'm
not condoning this. I'm just saying this
is how greens the mind works. So, he hit
the guy, kicked the guy, and he was out.
>> Mhm. for me to find out my friend has
got black belt in kickboxing.
>> But because they're quiet and shy, he
never told me this.
>> I'm like, I'm glad we didn't have the
fight,
>> you know? But the point is that's that's
the direction they go in.
>> And that's why many times,
unfortunately, they then live out those
video games that they are playing. They
these are the gamers, you know, these
computer shops that are open 24/7. You
play through the night. It's the greens
that will sit there. It's the nerds in
the school. M
>> they are the ones addicted more to the
video games and the series on television
etc.
>> So the reds when it comes to games
>> you know for a red and I'm a red and
it's in my mind also
>> and it's something that I need need
balance by asking God is that they need
to wake up every day and beat someone at
something.
>> That's that's how they operate. You know
you just need to beat someone at
something then they feel good about
themselves. So they like, you know,
sport games, these type of games where
I'm beating someone.
>> The yellows, they they it's more about
the crowd that's playing with them
>> than the game itself.
>> So it's like, yeah, let's invite all our
friends over and we land together, you
know? It's that so it's more the peer
pressure that gets them into gaming and
keeps them into gaming because they're
more people orientated. They want to be
out there and do something. the blues
fantasy games, you know, and where
you're building something, you need to
be strategic
>> and you, you know, takes time. It takes
you like five years to complete the
game. Those are the they have the
patience to do it.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's the same with Greens. They also
like those fantasy strategic type of
games, but also the first man shooter
games as I've just explained.
>> This is interesting. I grew up being a
gamer because my brother got me into it
and it was like the shooter games
>> and it was like the more strategic games
like RPGs and stuff but it was also the
Sims which is hugely family oriented and
I think I'm blue green so that's super
interesting.
>> So that's what attracted you and I
wasn't when I was gaming that wasn't
attracted to me at all. I was into
sports,
>> WWE wrestling and in our country cricket
and rugby. It's like I just I want to
beat you at sport. You know,
>> there's these long games. I actually
have to take time and think about it.
Yeah. I don't like that.
>> Yeah. See, I don't I don't like the
games that shoot each other. If there
was a game where you could just run
around and hug people, I'd be like
totally cool.
>> So, and and you can apply these
principles to social media, too. You
know, the Reds, they sometimes they're
not really into social media always
because it takes their times, distracts
them. But if they do and go to social
media, it's the sports, what's going on
in the sporting world, etc. The blues
would be the relational, you know, if
there's a family that has a channel that
the greens and the blues will be very
attracted to it and watch these family
wake up and go to the toilet and then
put on clothes. You know, they're
interested in the
>> so they because it's true life. It's a
reality, but it's not that real. And if
you think about it, we saw a picture the
other day of a couple taking a picture
on this amazing boat
on on a I don't know can't remember
where
>> like a cruise boat
>> like a cruise boat or just but it's like
a holiday
>> and it was just like look at our amazing
time but they were fighting all the time
afterwards. So the picture is a false
reality
>> and then that false reality is portrayed
to the world and say this is what life
is about and then the other people sit
there okay I don't have the money to go
on the cruise
>> and secondly in my home we fight all the
time.
>> Mhm.
>> So we as a family we share a lot about
our experience now in the US. We share
we've been here we've been there and I
could actually stand there and say you
know we're not fighting.
>> Do we have disagreements here and there
on our trip? Obviously,
>> but we are actually happy.
>> We are actually enjoying it together. Is
the trip getting a little bit long? No.
Yes, it does.
>> But the point is it's reality for us.
>> And that's what people are longing for.
And this is why we do the programs that
we do that the two principles to follow
to follow h to find happiness in this
life. Love God with all your heart and
all your soul. Love your neighbor as
yourself.
>> Amen. Relational. If you love God, you
will live a surrendered life which will
empower you to love your neighbor as
yourself. And you would treat that
person the way you want to be treated.
You would love that person to want
what's best for them.
>> And that's why we study this stuff and
present it to people so people can find
the joy we have found
>> in this life. God said, "I will bless
you in this life. You don't have to wait
for heaven. Yes, it's going to suck
because of trials and temptations and
the devil is real,
>> but God is with you. It's the safest
place to be on earth.
>> I also think that anything that you
consider satisfying in life takes work.
>> Yes.
>> I think that, you know, when things are
just easygoing and this and that, you
can see it doesn't mean the same. If
you've got the guy that worked very
difficultly, could make his make his
career and his life and his business or
whatever like that, then the other guy
who's like generation, they hand it to
him. they're they're just they don't
care, you know.
>> So, I think that, you know, working on
our relationships and having struggles
and and pains and stuff, it actually
draws us closer.
>> Exactly.
>> And we will have a close relationship
with God that the rest of the universe
>> won't quite understand from our
perspective, you know.
>> Exactly. That's what it's supposed to
do.
>> Trials in your relationships supposed to
draw you to each other, not drive you
apart. It can only draw you to each
other if God is the center.
>> If he's not the center, it will push you
apart. Because you can read all the
books out there, whether it's of your
church or denomination or not, they will
tell you marriages break off because of
people not being able to handle conflict
>> because the conflict drives them apart.
It doesn't drive them together.
>> And you I can tell you
>> every time my wife and I have had an
argument and I go on my I tell her I
just need to go to sleep. And then she
would tell me, "Do not let the sun go
down on your anger." And I'm like,
"Yeah, but it was night already when we
started arguing, so it only counts
tomorrow night."
>> If I go to sleep,
>> if I go to sleep and tomorrow morning,
the first thing I do is I spend time
with God. I go on my knees. Never, not
once, has God gone and say, "Yeah,
Renie, you're right. Your wife is
totally wrong.
>> She needs to change."
>> He's never said that.
>> He always says, "Humble yourself. go and
listen to what she's actually saying.
Stop arguing about the things you said
in the argument
>> and go to the root cause. Listen to her.
Let her explain herself and then be
humble enough to accept what she's
saying and then you can move on.
>> Mhm.
>> And that's the key.
>> So you mentioned you sell these
presentations on flash drives, right?
Yes. Where can people find those?
>> So obviously from our ministry, but we
want to make it available online for
those who are overseas. So I've got
obviously in the US I've got a bag full
of these flash drives.
>> Uh the the original design of the
marriage seminar at least is an online
seminar. So it's got PDF documents with
all the videos. I run through it.
>> Then after the one audience I was like
okay I'm going to tell them go online.
They're excited now. They forget by the
time they get home. Right.
>> But if I've got the flash drive here you
know people will just come and buy it
right now and they have it.
>> Can we do a little giveaway?
>> Oh we can do a giveaway. We can do
something like that. We we'll uh we'll
pick a random winner if you uh if you
want it. Um definitely kind of we'll put
the link in the description below and uh
you might be able to get one.
>> Definitely we can do that.
>> Check the description for instructions
on how to get.
>> So we have one for single people where I
do some of the marriage talks like the
communication and those things leave out
the sexual stuff which is only for
married couples. Um but then I have this
biblical seminar in that one where I go
splendid personalities in the first two
>> and then I go into the Bible. What does
the Bible say? how God's going to
prepare us for the end based upon who we
are.
>> Cool.
>> Awesome. That was super enlightening and
thank you so much for coming from so far
away to come over here and bless us and
our audience. But hope you guys had a
blessed time. Check him out. If you have
any questions, we'll leave his contact
information down there as well and you
can email them to him.
>> All right,
>> thank you.
>> If you like this video, like, subscribe,
>> and hit the notification bell so you
know when we launch new videos
>> and drop a comment below and we'll try
to get back to you if we can.
What?
>> Say that again.
>> No.
>> No. I don't know what to say.
[Music]